so earthquakes have left syrians with
very little infrastructure and support
and because of the unsanitary conditions
there is a fear of the spread of Cholera
the disease is caused by eating and
drinking contaminated food or water a
real risk here in the camps for those
displaced by the Civil War and now the
earthquakes
cholera is a fatal disease We Fear the
outbreak of the disease especially since
hygiene and sanitary Works have been
halted for 10 days we're not supplied
with clean water and wastewater can't be
drained away we call on relief agencies
to act swiftly
there are concerns that cams lack enough
resources to handle an outbreak
all Camp residents fear the spread of
Cholera especially in the absence of
necessary medical arrangements or
required medical Crews the disease is
likely to spread as people share toilets
which are few in number toilets are very
old a shortage of water and other
disinfectants and cleaning materials are
also a factor a cultural Treatment
Center has been set up it's basic but
it's all they can manage here
we had previous cases of Cholera and it
is exacerbated out of the recent
earthquakes the Quakes damage the sewage
systems and water pipes which resulted
in higher numbers of Cholera infections
the number of positive cases is on the
rise especially within the camps
for those affected this facility is a
Lifeline
following the earthquakes we moved to
one of the camps my son had fever
stomach ache and diarrhea he was also
vomiting constantly this is when we
realized he had cholera we tried some
drugs from the pharmacy but there was no
response so we came here its absence of
clean drink and water and cleaning
materials also sheratolis are among the
reason for the spread
there is a drive now by Aid agencies to
provide help to these people and there's
hope it will come sooner rather than
later before the disease spreads adding
to the syrian's plight I said Al Jazeera